for more than a decade Dennis Franz was
one of the most recognizable faces on
television thanks to his role as Andy
Sipowicz on NYPD Blue
but since the series wrapped in 2005 he
hasn't appeared in a single movie or TV
show why here's the real reason you
don't hear from Dennis Franz anymore
from 1993 to 2005 Dennis Franz anchored
NYPD Blue for train Andy Sipowicz for a
good chunk of the characters life as
well as his own 12 years is a long time
to hold a job and by the end of it Franz
had had enough instead of moving on to
another project he decided to just
retire he told the New York Post
I was just tired he was becoming a job
as much as I loved the work in the
challenges in the creative process I
just wanted to live an enjoyable
irresponsible spend time with my family
kind of life I haven't regretted one
minute of it I'm pretty good at doing
nothing Franz and his wife now spend a
lot of time at their lake house in
northern Idaho when they aren't
traveling around the world it sounds a
lot better than tracking down killers
every week Andy Sipowicz might be one of
the most famous TV cops of all time but
the character was far from the first law
enforcement officer Franz had played in
his long career in fact Franz told the
Los Angeles Times that by his own count
Sipowicz was the 28th police officer he
had portrayed across television movies
and theater he was so typecast that he
almost didn't take the NYPD blue gig at
all I told myself I was going to try to
find another vehicle it was time not to
play any more cop roles it's no wonder
he decided to retire
how's it feel take some via new stone
before teaming up with legendary TV
producer Steven Bochco on Hill Street
Blues and NYPD Blue among others
Franz made his name in film as a regular
for two of the most important and
singular directors of the 1970s and
1980s Brian De Palma and Robert Altman
Franz appeared in five DePalma movies
during the directors peak the fury
dressed to kill blowout Scarface and
body double he also joined Altman's
ensemble films a wedding Popeye and the
player sadly though Altman passed away
in 2006 while Bochco passed in 2018 and
while De Palma is still active his
output has slowed dramatically it's
understandable if Franz would rather
stay retired rather than go it alone
without any of his biggest creative
partners though he hasn't appeared on
screen in years Franz has had his fair
share of real-life drama
for instance in 2007 a huge chandelier
fell from the ceiling in Francis house
in Idaho injuring his sister Marlene the
two sued for negligence with Franz
revealing that as a result of the
accident he was forced to forgo a 16
million dollar personal services
contract which suggests fans might have
missed out on a possible comeback
project thanks to the faulty chandelier
and in 2010 Franz was involved in
another lawsuit claiming he was owed
nearly seventy thousand dollars by a
charter jet company for services he paid
for but never received luckily they were
able to come to an agreement before the
matter went to trial Dennis Franz hasn't
acted on-screen since 2005 so fans were
pleasantly surprised when he made an
unexpected appearance at the 2016 Emmys
it sparked rumors of a possible comeback
something the Franz told the New York
Post is still a possibility my agents
have an understanding they're still
gonna knock on my door periodically to
see if there are any home runs to get me
off my butt but so far that hasn't
presented itself though I left my
options open and didn't say I was for
sure closing the door and not leaving it
open a crack here's hoping someone
offers in a juicy role sometime soon
just no more cops okay
[Music]